it's like a talking dog movie it's
seemingly super sweet but it's filthy
R-rated I like this humping
be right
I'm there was a dog movie that wasn't
for kids
put your paws in the air
[Music]
sprays is about a sweet naive dog named
Reggie I have the best owner in the
world
the first time in his life he is astray
sorry mate welcome to the club he meets
very Street wise dog named bug you could
pretty much whatever you want I recently
this couch no that's not my line is she
dirty too I can tell looks like she
hasn't been washed in years I'll see you
later baby it was nice to meet you
Reggie and Bug connect with a group of
Strays who convince him to get revenge
on his owner Doug he's a horrendous
person
classic dug too funny I was just floored
by the unbridled shenanigans on an epic
hero's journey what are those kind of
looks like food
whoa
oh I'm 100 in for this it's just such a
fun ride can't wait to see it with a
group of people in theaters we're
completely lost and my little puppy paw
pads are really hurting right now so how
could this get worse
oh God hold on Buddy
holy
smoke weed every day